نبدا بملفنا الاول الذي يلقي الضوء على
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في اخر تطورات
الميدانيه اعلن الجهاز الامن الاوكراني
تضرر 76 هدفا على سبعه عشره بلده وقريه في
دنياز خلال الساعات 24 الماضيه
تفضل رئيس الاداره الاقليميه لمنطقه
اكد ان القوات الروسيه وصلت خلال ليله
الماضيه هجماتها على منطقه كييف وقال ان
الدفاعات الجويه
عدد من المسيرات فوق غابات
المنطقه الجويه الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه جنه الليله الماضيه هجوما باثنتين
وعشرين مسيرا انتحاريه وسته صواريخ من نوع
كاليبر واكدت ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اسقطت عشره مسيره وثلاثه
صواريخ كروز اطلقت من سفن روسيه في البحر
الاسود
قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ناتاليا ان القوات الروسيه
تكثف من هجماتها على اوكرانيا واعلنت ان
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت ثلاثه
صواريخ من نوع كاليبر في اجواء ميكولايف
في محيط عملياتنا اطلقت مجددا صواريخ
روسيه من منطقه البحر الاسود يواصل العدو
الضغط علينا ليلا ويبدو ان هذا اصبح عمله
المفضل في هذه المرحله اسقطنا ثلاثه
صواريخ من نوع كاليبر في اجواء ميكولايف
يحاول الغازات استنزاف قوه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانيه وتقليب الراي العام الداخلي في
ظل الحديث عن الهجوم المضاد المتوقع
لقواتنا
هيئه الارك
ان الات
هام مشيره الى وقوع اكثر من 29 اشتباكا
كان اعنفها في بخموت ومارينكا هذا واكدت
هيئه الاركاد الاوكرانيه افشال هجمات
للقوات الروسيه نحو المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]